I went through when I was 26 with this
one girl we were talking about I was
like yeah I don't want to have kids cuz
what you were saying Terry I don't want
to bring them into this crap hell ho but
I knew that was kind of fake we were
saying it out loud but in my head I was
like it's not really true though but I
did say I don't want to travel all over
the world like my job's traveling a lot
of it is it has been throughout the
years and I didn't want to leave him
behind when I went and traveled and I
don't want to be that Dad that wasn't
around like four days a week cuz I
wanted to tour I wanted to go tour and I
never ended up really touring but I
still want to go tour when I want to
tour but I I don't know it's it doesn't
but then the loneliness of just getting
on my computer and being like what
another one of these days like there's
more to life how is it I I think it's
just really interesting that North Korea
is experiencing this they they rule they
control culture with an iron fist so it
is interesting to see that's happening
all over the
place you know Russia when they Russia
did this huge experiment in the 1920s uh
to abolish the family and they were
really they were too successful